cinq ans de gestation pour que cette
maison voit le jour sur un terrain donné
par la ville de varennes en montérégie
pour des familles comme celle
d'alexandre c'est ma grande soeur mais
je la considère comme ma petite soeur
est tellement précieuse à mes yeux tout
le temps en train de re grand
soulagement de trouver un endroit comme
celui là avec des gens extérieurs de
notre réalité qui s'impliquent la dengue
qui ont bâti quelque chose d'aussi beau
merveilleux on serait peut-être au jour
une cohue qui a besoin notre besoin de
nous voici donc un milieu de vie
complètement adaptée aux particularités
sensorielle des adultes autistes via
beaucoup d'attention qui a été mis sur
le son sur la lumière parce que ce sont
des choses qui peuvent hériter les
personnes autistes en anglais dans des
miroirs dans salle de bain il y en a qui
y ont par carey mans où ça déclenche une
crise de se voir de voir leurs reflets
donc les miroirs ont été camouflés dans
des armoires tous les espaces communs
sont au rez-de-chaussée salon et salle
d'activités une grande cuisine et de
salle à manger
epinal ont compté c'est plus tranquille
à eau les chambres il y en avait en tout
formant cinq grappes autour d'un petit
salon elle a été construite et aménagé
au coût de 5 millions de dollars par la
fondation véro et louis mais c'est
beaucoup plus qu'une maison d'une vie
me diallo c'est beau jour dans la
surveillance
on sera donc un environnement stimulant
grâce aux services dispensés par le
réseau de la santé qui sera aussi
responsable de choisir les résidents
parmi ceux qui attendent un hébergement
on comprend ce qu'on voulait faire bon
comment on s'arrange ça peut fonctionner
une bonne idée de départ soutenu par l'
expertise clinique et la recherche
universitaire c'est tout à fait au
dessus je vous dirais aussi donc les
projets de recherche vont vraiment nous
aider à démontrer
l'aspect l'aspect novateur et si ça
donne les résultats escomptés c'est ce
qu'on souhaite puis c'est ce qu'on veut
vraiment puisse avoir sûrement ouvrir la
porte vers d'autres modèles
d'hébergement les besoins sont grands ce
qui fait que aujourd'hui on ouvre la
première maison mais j'espère que c'est
le début d'une grande aventure et qui
aura des dizaines de maisons à travers
le 4e tour - des parties qu'il a écrit
c'est tout ce dont rêvait celles qui
élèvent deux garçon autiste
c'est important pour moi qu'il ya de la
joie autant pour les gens qui
travaillent à la maison pour les
résidents aussi pour les parents qui
s'avère une grande paix d'esprit et je
sais de quoi je parle
leur intimité leur espace
doit être respectée et c'est ce qui
ressemble le plus
puis je mets entre parenthèses
anormalité ce qu on pourrait souhaiter
de mieux pour eux un endroit où elle
serait bien pour continuer à s'épanouir
et quand nous on serait plus capable
la maison est prête à accueillir en
douceur ses premiers résidents chez eux
ici anne louise des parties radio-canada
varennes